libraries are centers of information
they are where we store the collective
memories of the human species and
therefore they protect the history of
the Arctic after man started interacting
with the Arctic first the idea and then
the reality of it and later the loss of
it so I think libraries will be among
the most important places we have in
making people aware of what climate
change means and that it is actually
happening and the Arctic as a reference
point is invaluable because that is
where we see it most clearly that is the
climate change and its effects on this
planet and on human life because we
should never forget that the eds
of the Arctic the Arctic Circle has been
a home for human beings for millennia
and the news story is of course how the
people who have lived there are losing
their homes their hunting grounds and a
place they call home so I hope that
story is also in the archives because
the fate of the people who live by the
Arctic
is about the fate of humankind